les politiciens ont la mémoire courte
c'est bien connu côté occidental par
exemple eux on n'a strictement aucun
souvenir de ce soi-disant promesse de
non expansion de le temps à l'ess des
promesses qui aurait été fait il ya
trente ans un échange du relâchement de
l'étreinte soviétique sur les pays du
pacte de varsovie
tout d'abord l'otan n'a jamais donné de
garanties à gorbatchev ou à un autre
dirigeant soviétique concernant le fait
que l'organisation n'aurait pas de
nouveaux membres ensuite c'est la simple
idée que certains alliés importants
donnerait ce genre de carinthie ils
violent d'une certaine manière quelques
principes vraiment fondamentaux
ainsi aucune garantie de ce type n'a été
donnée
les gens disent qu'il est très
provocateur vis-à-vis de la russie que
la lettonie est décidé de devenir membre
de l'otan je veux dire cela suppose que
la lettonie ne peut pas faire ce qu'elle
veut parce qu'elle est voisine de la
russie et il s'agit là de la vieille
façon de considérer le droit des grandes
puissances
de décider ce que leur petit voisin peut
faire
sauf que à les archives américaines elle
se souvient très bien des mots du
secrétaire d'état de l'époque james
baker par exemple pousse vers l'est
disait-il le 9 février 1990 lors de sa
rencontre avec mikhaïl gorbatchev et il
était loin d'être le seul prenons le
secrétaire général de l'otan de 1988 à
1994 l'allemand manfred werner
monsieur verner a souligné que le
conseil de l'otan et lui-même étaient
opposés à l'expansion de l'otan treize
des seize membres de l'organisation
soutiennent ce point de vue dans un
avenir proche lors de sa rencontre avec
lech walesa et le dirigeant roumain ilie
et ce coup il s'opposera à l'adhésion de
la pologne et de la roumanie à l'otan
comme il l'a déjà fait pour la hongrie
et la tchécoslovaquie
nous ne devons pas permettre a déclaré
monsieur werner les allemands de l' urss
vis-à-vis de la communauté européenne ou
le premier ministre britannique john
major excusez du peu dont les propos
sont rapportés par l'ambassadeur de
grande-bretagne à moscou rodrigue bri
white
lors de la réunion avec les responsables
militaires qui a suivi le maréchal iazov
a exprimé ses inquiétudes quant à
l'intérêt des dirigeants d'europe de
l'est pour une adhésion à l'otan dans
son journal bref wait écrit major lui
assure que rien de tel ne se produira
vous en voulez encore alors voyons donc
ce qu'on disait un dietrich genscher
ministre des affaires étrangères et
vice-chancelier allemand révélé par ce
câble confidentiel des classes et de
l'ambassade américaine à destination de
james baker
d'un autre côté guen cher précise que
les changements en europe de l'est et le
processus d'unification allemande ne
doivent pas débouché sur une atteinte
aux intérêts de sécurité soviétique par
conséquent l'otan devrait exclure une
extension de son territoire vers l'est
c'est à dire en le rapprochant des
frontières soviétique guen cher ajoute
que la considération concernant
l'inclusion de la partie de l'allemagne
qui constitue aujourd'hui la rda dans
les structures militaires de l'otan
bloquerait le rapprochement allemagne
allemagne et des documents comme ça il y
en a plein encore les férus d'histoire
peuvent faire le tour des archives de la
sécurité nationale à l'université de
george washington c'est extrêmement
structurée mais visiblement personne a
le temps on ya mis les pieds depuis des
lustres et puis vous savez ce que c'est
les paroles s'envolent les écrits
restent c'est sans doute pour cela que
les autorités russes proposent
aujourd'hui pour désamorcer la crise
diplomatique actuelle de se mettre
d'accord par écrit sur cette question de
l'expansion de l'otan vers l'est le
scénario cauchemardesque d'un
affrontement militaire qui a déjà connu
notre continent est de retour après la
fameuse double décision de l'otan
l'europe garde le silence le bourrage
militaire de l'ukraine continue
renforçant la détermination de kiev à
saboter les accords de minsk et
nourrissant l'illusion de la possibilité
d'une solution militaire au conflit je
tiens à ce que ce soit très clair la
transformation de nos pays voisins en
tête de pont en vue d'un affrontement
avec la russie le déploiement des forces
de l'otan à proximité immédiate de zone
stratégiquement importante pour notre
sécurité est catégoriquement
inacceptable il est temps de transformer
2 juste parole en garanties de sécurité
à long terme et juridiquement
contraignant on se demande bien ce qui
peut l'enquêté le temps ne s'aventure et
pas dans de hasard deux opérations
militaires au risque de semer l'eau car
on a faim sauf si l'on n'ait eu beau
slaves ou afghans ou les biens et demain